guess who's back again  Bruno Mars is back with new music and  the sexiest gig in the world the 2016  Victoria's Secret Fashion Show we're  trying to party with you Bruno ET can  exclusively reveal the superstar singer  will perform during the annual lingerie  runway show taking place this year in  Paris for the first time ever no doubt  we'll have incredible music and plenty  of sultry ensembles worn by angel  favorites like Adriana Lima Alessandra  Ambrosio Lily Aldridge and Jasmine tooks  who will rock the $3,000,000 bright  night Fantasy Bra  watch Bruno Mars on the Victoria's  Secret Fashion Show when it airs Monday  December 5th at 10:00 p.m. on CBS no  break